we should make the most satisfying
simulated
render one more one
hopefully i can get it all done in time
peter
which one is the winner i think it's
time to let everybody know
i was really jealous last year because
while i was away these guys got to have
a ton of fun
making the most satisfying renders
like when i saw those satisfying renders
i thought you know what
it's just as satisfying to make them as
it is to watch so
i had to be in i i feel like sam it's
great to have you on this one it's going
to be awesome
my goal here is to make a render so
satisfying it lowers everyone's heart
rate especially your sam
because i know you got two kids and you
know your sleep just ain't
what it used to be in my opinion the two
things
that last challenge did really well
having them
loop is great you watch it you don't
know where it starts
or ends it's just a perfect
infinitely looping image the moment you
see one of these things cut
you're like it's like jarring and you're
back in reality your heart rate goes
through the roof from here forth all
satisfying render challenges
will always loop the sound design is
very important
to getting that like satisfying feeling
so we we definitely need to like not
miss that this time as well
so the last renders were really cool but
one thing that was missing was
physics satisfying things can be made by
hand but when you watch
nature take its course and deliver you
something beautiful and satisfying it is
i think one of the most purest
experiences a render can give you
for this challenge we should try our
best to make the most
satisfying simulated render
using motion and using physics
specifically it doesn't matter what it
is
it can be particles it can be rigid
bodies it can be soft bodies
it could be flaccid bodies
a flaccid body simulation is one of the
hardest goals to achieve
as a visual effects artist so you're
saying the bulk of our animations
can't be hand animated they have to be
simulated yes like take
take the artist's hand out of this let
the ones and zeros
create the satisfaction for us that
sounds good to me it sounds like a good
challenge
my expectation on this is to be able to
like i want to learn something
along the way so that we just get a
little bit better and can make better
videos after this video
today is tuesday and we're going to
watch these renders
next monday and that might seem like a
lot of time but
we have a dozen other things to do other
than this in the meantime
so we're going to be sneaking in minutes
on this every
chance we get hey what are you doing
here are you guys doing a render
challenge without me
no no we're just doing um
oh clint clint's gone i gotta
check my oil i like oil
hey have you guys seen ren no i'm just
trying to find him
red red
hi ren red what you doing up here so
they told me to wait up here on the roof
until they're ready to do the render
challenge and so i thought while i'm
waiting i might as well listen to a book
i got a pretty good one that i listened
to recently and i want to tell you about
it because this is sponsored by
audible is audible leader in spoken word
entertainment i've listened to almost
100 titles on this platform at this
point i love it so a recent one i
listened to is called an
absolutely remarkable thing by an og
youtuber named hank
green you might know his brother he's
dead books so this title basically
starts off with
64 robots showing up across the world
now i'm not saying they're aliens but
aliens so the main protagonist of the
audiobook she finds this robot and her
and her friend make this youtube video
about it and then the next day she
becomes like a viral hit it touches on a
lot of things that felt a little too
close to home about like insecurities
and
how social media corrupts the mind the
book is incredible i literally listened
to the entire 10 hour book in two days
on audible and speaking of audible they
just launched a new plan
called audible plus you get full access
to their plus catalog which is filled
with thousands upon
thousands of originals audiobooks and
podcasts
including ad-free versions of all the
shows that you'd normally have ads on
so with the audible membership you can
download or stream without
lemon and of course you can also do
offline listening anytime
anywhere to get your free 30-day trial
all you got to do is go to audible.com
quarter crew or just simply text quarter
crew to 500-500 again
just go to www.audible.com
corridor crew or you can use your little
smart phony thing and you can text cora
crew one word to 500 500
and you will get your free 30-day trial
30 days free
all right ran well good luck up here
good luck with the book
thanks uh just make sure you let me know
before they start the render challenge
or send someone up here
that'd be great yeah good luck good luck
with the book man
good luck with the book so last time i
bit off way more than i could chew
and ended up getting points off because
my render quality was just crap
but this time i learned my lesson what i
want to do is make something that
justifies satisfying sound design
alright so singing bowl i don't know the
history of this thing but basically
you give it a little tap
and then you gotta like do the little
in yoga they'll use it for what's called
a sound bath which is just like a
really weird i don't even know i just
like the way it sounds
that's probably the biggest inspiration
of this whole render all right so i just
had an idea i'm pretty excited about i
was messing around with this cool new
feature that blender just got where you
can take a smoke simulation and turn
that into geometry polygons points in
space
and i did like the most basic smoke
simulation and i noticed it looked a
little bit like a mushroom
so i was thinking what if i use this
smoke simulation to mesh converter
to show plants growing in a really
psychedelic way
like for a tree i have one smoke
simulation just going straight up for
the trunk and then
a bunch of little particles flying out
the sides for some branches and then
an explosion at the top for the leaves
so i'm gonna dig my thingies into
blender and see what happens
my son gideon great kid he loves food
cheez-its peanuts goldfish graham
crackers he's great at eating them
not so good at keeping them in the bowl
so
i'm on my hands and knees pretty
frequently with a little vacuum while it
might seem like a strange thing to be
satisfying
well it gets quite satisfying and i
think that's what i'm gonna try and
recreate
i'm gonna make a cg vacuum that cleans
up dust and creates the cleanest
carpet so i've been playing around with
the smoke to mesh function in blender
and it's been working out pretty well so
i think a nice render would be kind of a
slow camera move through a forest of
these weird little smoke simulation
plants watching them grow and act all
strange
so i think my next step here is to make
a couple smoke simulations that
mimic trees plants i'm just going to
make my own little library of smoke
simulations that i can then
populate the forest with i need to see
how these physics systems work
i've never really done anything like
this but i think using x particles i
might be able to do it
gravity okay gravity so crumbs come out
boom
someone just ate a cracker and that's
the crumb all right and now suck them up
they're definitely going there all right
i'm on my way
last time my loop was not successful
it may have appeared successful but if
you really looked at it
now basically in order to get this thing
to loop what i did
was hand place all of my bowls here all
my singing bowls
and then i added them into a cloner
and it's being cloned three times down
the line here so you're getting like
the exact same pattern three times i'm
taking my camera
and i'm moving it down along the z-axis
at a very specific
rate everything's based on the math
right so you want to break up
everything exactly so for instance
my camera's moving negative 2800
centimeters
on the z axis so i'll take my cloner and
i'm and i'm making sure that i'm
moving my new clones negative 2800
centimeters on the z-axis
so everything kind of lines up so i'm
lighting my scene with
two area lights now if i just left these
area lights in place
the first frame wouldn't match the last
frame because the camera is moving but
the lights wouldn't be so what i'm doing
here is i'm actually throwing these
lights
into my camera so the camera
and the lights are moving together that
way the first frame
is exactly lit as the last frame if you
can get your first and last frame to
match perfectly
then everything else in between you can
do whatever the heck you want
i think the core mechanic here of these
vacuums is working it looks satisfying
so
piece by piece i'm gonna render out a
bunch of different sets that loop
into each other here and i'm just gonna
populate this with interesting objects
now
so i got my scene all blocked out and
i've started adding in my smoke
simulations but i've hit a bit of a
bottleneck
i'm going to need a lot of smoke
simulations for the scene where there's
a bunch of vegetation growing and things
like that
and each smoke simulation is taking way
too long to do if i'm going to get this
render done in any amount of time i'm
going to need to switch over to a faster
solution so
i've been using embergen which is this
new software that runs
smoke simulations on your gpu it's way
faster it's basically real time
and it's amazing so i'm going to jump
over to ambergen and make some smoke
zones
so for physics what i did was i cut out
these little like
grooves in the concrete portion of my
render
and i pushed these metal spheres
down the chute kind of like a little
bobsled situation
and it's all physics based which i could
have cheated easily but i didn't
just for the record i didn't cheat it
for all the textures and stuff i'm using
grayscale gorillas everyday materials
and i'm using some of my
own surface imperfections that i created
for the metal spheres
to give them a little bit of smudge and
scratch on them and if you guys want to
know how to make your own
surface imperfections i actually have a
youtube channel and a video dedicated to
exactly that i walk you through the
entire process it's actually a lot of
fun
so i've been playing around with these
smoke simulations turning them into
foliage and it feels very percussive and
so i was thinking it might be fun
to create a little music piece and have
the video go along with that so
last night i sat down on my keyboard and
i made a little song and the next step
is to bring that song into blender kind
of map out the scene a little bit so i
know
where things are going to be and what
it's going to look like so i can save
myself from doing a bunch of work that's
not going to end up in the shot
putting all my renders into sequence
here i rendered these out in the order i
started working on them
they iterate they get each one gets a
little bit more complicated as it goes
dude it's turned out i think pretty cool
i don't have any sound for it no that's
kind of a requirement so hopefully i'll
sneak that in at some point
just it's just gonna be this the whole
time i'm oh wait
i'm totally gonna do the sounds of my
mouth screw them it works
it works dude it freaking works that's
so cool
i'm gonna render the high res over the
weekend and i'm gonna come back monday
morning and do the sound design
hopefully
i can get it all done in time satisfying
renders to me are a relaxing thing and i
tried not to get too stressed out about
how intense or satisfying it was and
just make something that came naturally
you know i don't want to stay up to 4am
doing this
peter
it was late night was until 5 30. i
don't even know if this is good
it just it's really weird final day dude
i'm doing sound design
i'm trying to create different versions
of a sound and i'm trying to stack them
together to make
an even nicer sound i'm trying to figure
out this program called paul stretch
look at this i can stretch a sound out
look at this i can stretch this sound
out
59 million years
i rendered this at like like 540p it's
got it looks god-awful hopefully it
finishes rendering on my home computer
i can upload it using my crappy wi-fi
it's time to do some sound design
hopefully i finish it and um
i know i'll finish in time these stakes
are garbage
guys today's the day myself sam and
peter cranked super hard over the last
couple days to get our satisfying
renders in and now is the time
we have two gentlemen here which we will
aim to satisfy
let's see if they are satisfied hey guys
what's your current heart rate right now
nico yeah i got my heart rate so right
now i'm i'm sitting at a cool
70 i'm at 66. i'm gonna get this boy to
50.
you're gonna drop this man's heart rate
to 50. i'm going to put niko in the
hospital i'll take him down to 30 feet
so at the beginning of this i said i
wanted to compete because
rendering was just so fun and pure and
innocent but i lied
the reason i wanted to be in on this
challenge is because last time peter won
a computer
wait is that computer still up for grabs
i
am going to win that computer back today
no
no i'm not going back to the 10 whatever
get rent get out of here right this is
invite only
why are you here explicitly against
their orders i just wanted to
see your guys's renders so you're just
here to you're just here to
i'm just here to look i'm just hanging
out in the background yeah stick around
maybe i can satisfy you sam i bet you
could satisfy me can you satisfy me
right now
it'd be my pleasure it'll be friend's
pleasure too you'll make him feel good
oh liquid
oh my god it keeps going
uh-oh oh that's the best one by far
that's so good
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh one more
one more
my heart rate's a zero
i can die satisfied finally this looks
so good
this is something you want to watch over
and over dude your colors
and your textures and your sound this
one's wonderful and the thing is like
not only is it beautifully rendered it's
a classic like focused
single action great sound design but for
some of the sims it's all about
like they clean up every single object
you somehow made it so like every single
thing gets sucked up
at least since we are judging and being
you know critics on this i was actually
thinking the time the two times where it
missed
made it less satisfying
it looks like the marbles just got
missed so that made it a tiny bit less
satisfying for me but otherwise
i think i was at 9 or 10 and then 8.5
because that took me
specific out of it but for nico it was
more satisfying
10 out of 10. standing ovation
peter yeah the winner the returning
champ dude this is uh you guys ready for
some 240p
video oh dude that's what happened to me
last time that's what happened
here we go some uh oh it's something i
don't know what it is
i don't even know if it's good but it's
at least something and it's done
and it's ready to show so here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
hit
[Music]
oh
all right there you go it is pretty nice
the palm trees
i totally just realized were like kind
of like explosions
yeah shot up
well it is it is a perfect loop and i
like the whole symbolic you know
force gets burned down and it grows up
again but it does feel like more like a
longer music video
so if you ever took like a drawing class
in like high school
and there's the one kid that just does
their own thing and they're really good
but has nothing to do with the
assignments the teacher struggles to
like figure out how to give them a grade
it's kind of the situation we're in
right now
peter i'm sorry i'll give you a six out
of ten i'll keep it in the six to seven
range there
that's fine and i understand i'll take
it no hard feelings
this would have been a lot more
satisfying if you had the render
settings turned up a little bit
i know yeah i know hey if you wait till
the end you might see the non
240p version of this render who knows if
sam got a 10 that means the only way i
can tie with you is if i get a 10.
or an 11. all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
this is like top page reddit stuff for
me
[Music]
i'm too distracted by how photoreal this
looks to be satisfying i'm just like wow
look at the detail in every single one
of those
bowls yeah it's a it's just a flawless
render straight up this is
the best render i've ever seen clint
make but as for the satisfaction
it's just kind of stick spinning over
bowls
but what can i do you know i feel like
for something to be satisfying
something you need to be changing like
dust getting wiped off a surface
or like soft red being sliced by a sharp
knife
i'm gonna have to give it an 8.5 it's a
nice 10 out of 10 for me
this is a tie breaker situation guys
hold up hold up
i had an idea for a shot
and i couldn't i couldn't let these guys
swiggity swag their way into the finish
line without some competition from yours
truly so
they don't know it yet but i made my own
satisfying render
i ended up just coming to the studio
yesterday and did the entire shot
and i was up all night doing it so i
have been a week since
yesterday you can't keep me out of this
challenge
you can't keep me down look at this
right here oh it's a flash drive whoa
you can't do this you can't do this you
can't do it no don't play
this is really good i love this one yeah
this is this is super cool i love the
like the rainbow bread this is a
luxurious render
this is great i don't know if it beats
the singing bowls for me but
i'll give it a eight eight eight point
nine eight point nine
eight point five seconds i mean i'll
take the 8.9
you gave it 8.5 huh look bryn this is
really good
i'm gonna give it a nine all right there
has to be a winner
you gotta choose what are we gonna do
what do we do with the tie all right
we're gonna come back down what do we do
one of you guys is getting a 30-90
oh i was like joking i was gonna buy one
regardless
well it's still kind of like buying one
if the studio pays for it
clint's looked really nice but we're
talking about satisfaction
something about it being like an
intricate perfect clockwork
i think would have made that system work
but it's not really an intricate perfect
clockwork
it's just kind of a bunch of bowls with
the spinning handles just looking at it
clint's obviously
realistically looks perfect but i could
agree there could have been maybe one
other thing that really
pushed it over the edge so my only doc
is sam's like
glitches but i don't know if that makes
it less satisfying
which one is the winner i think it's
time to go downstairs
and let everybody know
all right christian and i thought really
hard about this
and then we stopped thinking and we
started feeling
and then our hearts spoke to us
sam congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
sam you satisfied me this is
about satisfying each other all right
and
you know i'm just happy that i brought
you that satisfaction you crave
so oh i'm hitting 58 right now dude i'm
at 86.
all these surrenders were very
satisfying peter i really look forward
to when you complete your render
i would really like to do this again
let's do it again let's do it again
i really want to do this again if you
guys want to see another satisfying
render challenge definitely subscribe
like this video leave a comment down
below
if you would like to see the final
renders in their most pure form
head on over to our instagram page at
corridor digital we have them all up
there
share them with your friends you can
stare at them for hours whatever you
want to do it's a good time
also we post other fun pictures and
videos imagine that
quarter digital on instagram wow guys
thanks this means a lot
um peter uh just show me where you leave
your computer and i'll
snag that i'll wipe it tonight for you
yeah yeah thanks yeah
it's time i'm actually working on the
luke skywalker do you think right now
um yeah i know i know don't worry
there's more videos don't worry
we gotta we got one on the back all
right
this sucks
[Music]
hey this game's pretty sick